the Joe Rogan experience having this
conversation in 2009 no I want to kill
bill cuts wrong with you he's America's
dad there's someone right now that we
could be having this conversation about
that we we don't know that we don't know
don't think anybody is like that not
like that cuz I heard about that guy in
1994 when I was on news radio when I was
on a sitcom they were talking about Bill
Cosby drugged young people and I forget
who was having the conversation but they
were like Bill Cosby drugs people and I
was like what like yeah like it was like
inside Hollywood talk like on the set
they were saying that someone knew
someone who Bill Cosby drugged he drugs
women has sex with him he would he wrote
jokes about it yes he talked about late
night TV slipping a spanish fly in
someone's drink yes he wrote an episode
of his show where he was like at a
barbecue and like there's something in
the barbecue sauce and the girls are
kind of like yes yes isn't that crazy
dude you know what's been happening to
me is that so I like I have been like
you know talking with guys texting with
guys facetiming like all these
long-distance stuff because I'm scared
of intimacy whatever and I've been
having these like really intimate
moments with men where it's like our
relationship reaches that like oh this
might be something let's maybe meet up
and we make plans and I find out the
next day they were and I think they're
like maybe on my way to be my boyfriend
and they were on ambien and they don't
remember any of it I've been ambient a
couple times and I don't think and by
guys that I'm like they are the drinking
problem I'm finally engaging in like a
sober relationship or sober ish and then
they they and they don't remember
anything and I'm like we made plans to
go to Mexico together like you like
Priceline I can't get a [ __ ] dream I
made dinner when he was on ambien dude I
thought someone broke into his house
like he went to the store and got like a
turkey and cooked it made mashed potato
stuffing graving they did the whole
thing
cooked yeah and then woke up at the
morning and they were like what did you
do last night you coach like what I
didn't [ __ ] cook
like I really thought someone broke into
his house and cooked dinner that stuff's
horrible yeah it's so good guys waking
up in relationships with me and they're
like they did it no way they're ready to
go to Mexico like what What's My
Passport doing out they'd in I don't
like you like that and then I'm like
pull wheat and I go to sleep with like
butterflies in my stomach like God we
finally connected tonight something
happened he finally saw what I saw the
whole time
and the next day I'll make like I'll
kind of like be like so last night like
one day one guy we had phone sex for the
first time we were like and it felt like
real sex you know sometimes it can feel
very connected phone sex or FaceTime
Skype sex whatever it is this guy live
mid middle of the country okay yeah and
I was in New York gonna say Midtown
Midtown oh why just get in the mood this
is crazy
[Laughter]
yeah we we finally like got naked
together on the and I was like oh my god
like this is and it was never really
sexual before that like there was a
little flirty things I was like when is
this guy gonna make a [ __ ] move and
like and he did but he was on ambien in
blacked-out siient didn't remember any
of it I was skipping around I was like
dude I telling all my girlfriend's like
I met a got like this guy is like the
guy that I've been talking to them about
I have a radio show us every morning I
go in and like debrief my producers I'm
like last night we like hooked up and
it's happening and and then I talk to
him later on and he was just like wait
what are you talking about I was like
and he goes I don't really know we
talked last night and was it just sucked
and then it happened to me recently
again there's a lot of people on that
show a lot I did it recently my friend
gave it to me because I I guess I
shouldn't say that but my I took some
and you shouldn't say that you just
don't say the friend's name yeah okay
you're all right okay
so [ __ ] [ __ ] gave you I was
working with Bill Cosby and didn't even
mean to he was my friend and because I
was just having a really rough time I
did the roast of Alec Baldwin and I was
not getting enough sleep which I know
you guys were talking about the other
night sleep is [ __ ] everything yeah
and I had a meltdown and I had a Netflix
taping to do the next night my friend
was like take this ambien you're not
gonna sleep otherwise and I took it and
it and I took Instagram off my phone if
hook took Twitter off my phone I cleared
my room of food because you don't know
what's gonna happen
got the best night's sleep of my life
those things off your phone oh yeah I
was like I don't know if I'm gonna get
racist when I do ambien what if that is
what it causes him you planned that far
ahead you know Instagram on phone so my
ambien state would have had to go into
the App Store redownload it type in my
you know like a lot of things yeah it's
a very clever thing that's very smart of
you I don't want to get cancelled yet I
mean someday I will want to get
cancelled because that surprise again
yeah a mix no not even to rise again to
be like good I'm out I'm gonna go start
my bird rescue or whatever the hell you
know yeah it'll be I'll be okay
[Applause]